"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Antoine Glaser, on dit souvent :
la politique africaine
de la France n'existe plus,
il n'y en a plus,
mais c'était quoi exactement,
la politique africaine
de la France ?
-Il y a une politique africaine
de la France
des indépendances de 1960
jusqu'à la chute du mur de Berlin.
Il y a eu une vraie politique
africaine, qui était
une période historique
avec un système intégré,
politique, militaire, financier,
qu'on a appelé globalement
la Françafrique.
Mais qui était une politique
qui correspondait
à une période historique. C'était
la période de la Guerre froide.
Les alliés de la France laissaient
gérer l'ensemble de ses anciennes
colonies à sa guise,
en particulier
toutes les prébendes
de l'uranium.
Il faut se rappeler qu'en 62,
la France s'était
fait virer de l'Algérie
et donc a retrouvé
des ressources pétrolières
dans ce golfe de Guinée,
du Gabon et du Congo.
Le Gabon, on l'appelait le pays PUM,
pétrole, uranium et manganèse.
Il y a une pile atomique
pour l'uranium.
Et donc, c'était, pour moi, il y a
eu vraiment une période historique,
le reste n'existe pas.
-C'est ça.
Et la figure centrale,
c'était Jacques Foccart
qui était un gaulliste
de la première heure.
-Mais il faut pas quand même oublier
que, finalement,
c'est l'Afrique
qui a en partie aidé
ou qui a libéré la France
du nazisme.
Et donc c'était certain
que ce petit bonhomme qui avait géré
pendant très longtemps
les services secrets français
à travers un organisme, le BCRA,
à partir de Londres, ce qui restait
de la France libre
était en Afrique
et finalement, Foccart,
il a repris ses pantoufles
à partir du moment
où, finalement,
l'Afrique a libéré la France
et donc il a repris
dans les années 60,
il a repris
tous ses réseaux.
Et c'est pour ça qu'il y a eu
tout ce côté mystérieux,
parce que c'est vrai
que c'était d'abord,
il s'est appuyé
sur les services secrets français.
-Et c'était vraiment
du néocolonialisme
à cette époque-là ?
-Oui, parce que Foccart...
-On parlait
du pré carré d'ailleurs.
-Encore une fois, pour moi,
je vois une période historique.
Jacques Foccart, on avait été
l'interviewer avec Steven Smith
à l'époque à Luzarches chez lui,
il était déjà très âgé.
-Dans la région
parisienne. Et lui,
quand on lui demandait,
mais alors, pour vous,
la Françafrique ?
Il dit, oui, il disait
avec une espèce de bonhomie,
ce qui est bon pour la France,
c'est bon pour l'Afrique.
A l'époque,
c'était vraiment les gens
qui ont cru
à une communauté de destins
entre la France et l'Afrique
et lui, voilà,
il verrouillait tout.
Il fallait que tous ces pays
votent comme un seul homme
aux Nations Unies
et c'était vraiment
une sorte d'assimilationnisme
entre la France et l'Afrique.
C'était vraiment une période
où on considérait que c'était
une petite France en Afrique.
-Petite France en Afrique,
donc les gouvernements,
bien qu'après l'indépendance,
étaient étroitement assujettis
finalement à ce que pensait,
à ce que voulait Paris.
-Il faut quand même pas oublier
qu'avant les indépendances,
un certain nombre
de présidents africains,
comme le président Houphouët-Boigny
de Côte d'Ivoire,
le président Léopold Sédar Senghor
du Sénégal, ont été
ministres
dans des gouvernements français.
On oublie comment le général Eyadema
du Togo,
il a crapahuté
avec l'armée française,
non seulement en Indochine,
mais en Algérie.
Celui qui est devenu
l'empereur Bokassa en Centrafrique,
il avait également été dans l'armée
française. Ces types-là étaient
en train de tirer sur les Algériens
ou en Indochine, etc.
Donc on oublie à quel point
il y avait cette communauté
d'Africains qui étaient intégrés
dans un dispositif français.
-Alors, après, vous dites
à la chute du mur de Berlin,
là, ça commence à changer.
Il y a le discours de la Baule
inspiré ou écrit plus ou moins
par Erik Orsenna
d'ailleurs, en 1991.
Et là, ça commence à changer, il y a
plus de politique africaine ?
-Non, je pense qu'Erik Orsenna
a écrit ça sur un coin
de table et c'est pas ça. C'est
simplement qu'à un moment donné,
à la chute du mur de Berlin,
tout le monde regardait
la réunification de l'Allemagne,
mais la France ne voyait pas
l'Afrique se mondialiser.
C'est ça,
le fond de l'affaire.
Cette période historique,
on va pas refaire l'histoire,
mais on pourrait, on aurait pu
imaginer que le président français
avec ses pairs africains
de cet ancien pré carré
fasse une grande réunion,
pas un petit texte de la Baule,
mais une grande réunion
en disant l'Afrique
se mondialise,
on passe à autre chose, etc.
En fait, la France
s'est un peu endormie
sur sa rente politique,
économique dans cette région
et n'a pas vu
l'Afrique se mondialiser.
On a l'impression que la France
s'est réveillée récemment
en disant, mais comment, qu'est-ce
qui se passe en Afrique ?
Mais l'Afrique s'est mondialisée.
Dans les années 2000,
ce sont d'abord les Chinois
qui ont réactivé l'Afrique.
-On parle de la Chinafrique.
-Et ensuite,
les propres partenaires
européens de la France.
On n'a pas vu non plus
que l'Allemagne est devenue
le premier exportateur européen
vers l'Afrique.
On n'a pas vu que les Italiens
reprenaient langue avec la Libye,
avec des anciennes colonies,
les Espagnols avec aussi... vu
comment ils reconnaissent maintenant
le Sahara occidental,
la marocanité
sur le Sahara occidental.
On est dans des périodes historiques
et la France est vraiment endormie
dans son ancien pré carré,
n'a pas vu la mondialisation
de l'Afrique.
-Quand il y a eu le coup
d'Etat en 1999 en Côte d'Ivoire,
il y avait
la cohabitation en France,
Jospin n'a rien dit et Chirac,
président de la République,
n'a rien dit non plus.
On a laissé faire et il y a
une dérive de la Côte d'Ivoire.
-Ca s'est pas vraiment
passé comme ça.
L'ancien conseiller Afrique Michel
Dupuch a essayé de faire réagir,
même en cas de cohabitation,
et c'était le coup d'Etat
du père Noël en Côte d'Ivoire
et Dupuch a essayé
de réagir
et à un moment donné,
les conseillers Afrique, que ce soit
autant à l'Elysée, à l'Elysée,
c'était Dupuch,
mais la cohabitation,
du Premier ministre, Lionel Jospin,
ils sont tous partis en vacances
et ils ont éteint leurs portables
ils ont dit à Dupuch,
si vous arrivez à faire bouger
la CEDEAO, la Communauté
des Etats d'Afrique de l'Ouest,
si vous avez un certain nombre
de chefs d'Etat africains
qui veulent réagir, on verra,
mais sinon, ils ont laissé tomber,
parce que c'était
une période de cohabitation.
Il y a eu des retours, que ça soit
au moment aussi de la chute
de Laurent Gbagbo
en Côte d'Ivoire en 2011.
Il y a eu des périodes
où il y a eu des retours,
où la France s'est imposée
militairement.
Mais, je veux dire,
globalement,
cette fin de période était quand
même une fin de période historique.
-Et donc,
en 2007, on est
au mois de juillet,
juste après l'élection
de Nicolas Sarkozy,
il va à Dakar, reçu
par le président Abdoulaye Wade,
et il fait un discours
dans lequel il dit,
l'homme africain n'est pas rentré
dans l'histoire, un discours
qui aurait été écrit, et il l'a été
en partie, par Henri Guaino.
Et là, évidemment,
grande polémique,
rupture même quasiment.
Les Africains ont pas compris.
-C'est affligeant,
parce que c'est une méconnaissance
de l'Afrique.
J'ai jamais entendu
jusqu'à ce jour
un président français dire :
il faut apprendre de l'Afrique.
Apprendre de l'Afrique,
ce continent
incroyable
à tous les points de vue,
pas simplement
pour ses matières premières,
sociologique, son humanité,
apprendre de l'Afrique.
On voit bien qu'il y a
une telle méconnaissance,
on a toujours l'impression
qu'il y a la métropole
et le continent africain.
Ca veut dire, c'est encore
une pensée ancienne,
pas du tout
une pensée moderne.
Ca veut dire, c'est
une méconnaissance de l'Afrique.
Ca veut dire, il faut que
l'Afrique apprenne de la France.
Ils sont pas assez rentrés
dans l'histoire,
il faut qu'ils revoient
leur histoire de France.
-En 2011 cette fois,
il y a les Printemps arabes
qui commencent en Tunisie,
mais il y a aussi un événement
qui va être tout à fait fondamental
pour l'avenir de l'Afrique,
c'est la chute de Khadafi.
Et déjà ce pays qui était pas
vraiment un Etat constitué,
qui tenait par un homme,
va se déliter,
et là, ça va changer toute la face
de l'Afrique de l'Ouest au moins.
Vous êtes d'accord
pour dire que ça a été
un élément capital
de l'histoire
de l'Afrique moderne,
contemporaine ?
-Absolument. Quand on voit, parce
qu'il faut quand même s'appuyer,
si moi, je dis que c'était
une erreur fondamentale,
on dit, OK, Glaser,
il connaît pas.
Mais quand on voit
Barack Obama qui considère
dans le livre qu'il a écrit,
dans ses mémoires,
qui considère
que c'est sa principale erreur
dans sa politique
des affaires étrangères,
c'est pas moi qui le dis.
-Il était en back-office.
-Evidemment.
Ils disent carrément qu'ils se sont
fait un peu entraîner, pas un peu,
ils se font entraîner
par les Français.
C'est certain que,
même les Anglais ont reconnu
que c'était aussi
une erreur fondamentale.
Joe Biden, à l'époque
vice-président des Etats-Unis,
avait dit, il était
contre cette intervention,
il avait dit, il faut pas y aller
si on voit pas à 10 ans,
si on voit pas
ce qui va se passer après.
Pour ceux qui connaissent
la région,
on savait qu'il y avait
un équilibre précaire.
C'est vrai que Khadafi faisait
les fins de mois
des chefs d'Etat
de la région.
Le grand frère algérien,
c'était la sécurité.
Ca allait mal
entre Algérie et Libye
quand les Libyens installaient
un consulat au nord du Mali.
Mais il y avait une sorte
d'équilibre, un équilibre précaire.
Après, on peut
raconter effectivement
sur le roi des rois.
Khadafi, je dis pas
que c'était pas un dictateur.
Mais encore une fois,
c'était pas l'affaire
des Occidentaux d'intervenir
sur ce continent, alors que
l'Union africaine était contre.
Tout le monde était contre.
C'est quelque chose
qui est fondamental.
C'était une armurerie, la Libye.
-C'était une armurerie, oui.
-Une armurerie à ciel ouvert.
Un certain nombre d'armements,
en particulier, on a vu
comment les Touaregs
qui étaient dans la légion
islamique de Khadafi
sont rentrés avec armes
et bagages au nord du Mali.
Au Niger, les Nigériens ont su mieux
gérer le retour des Touaregs armés,
parce qu'ils les ont intégrés
dans l'appareil d'Etat.
Mais ça a quand même déstabilisé
en partie toute cette région.
Et les djihadistes du GIA,
du groupe islamique algérien,
ceux qui étaient en Algérie, en ont
profité pour faire des alliances
avec les Touaregs
qui rentraient de Libye.
C'est là où tout a commencé
en fait.
-Toute l'affaire du Sahel
dont on parle aujourd'hui, c'est là.
-Absolument.
-Et c'est là où
on est confronté
à ce qu'on a appelé
une espèce de tentative
de constitution
de khalifat, ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait vrai non plus,
parce que ce sont des groupes
qui les uns les autres
se combattent,
qui n'ont pas tous
les mêmes objectifs,
qui, pour beaucoup,
relèvent plus, je dirais,
de la grande délinquance
que de la volonté
de créer un Etat islamique.
Mais tout ça fait
que la France intervient
en 2013 avec François Hollande.
Ca deviendra la force Barkhane
et finalement,
ce sera un échec, ça.
-Oui. On va pas refaire l'histoire,
mais c'est vrai que,
quand on parle de djihadistes,
c'est avant tout des groupes armés,
qui ont des territoires, c'est
vraiment les grandes caravanes,
c'est d'abord
des trafics en tous genres.
C'est une économie informelle.
C'est vraiment une période
historique aussi qui se termine.
C'est une période pour moi
qui est postcoloniale.
Depuis la Mauritanie
jusqu'au Soudan,
on voit que toute cette période,
il y a plus d'Occidentaux
dans toute cette région.
Il suffit de regarder une carte du
quai d'Orsay pour se rendre compte
que tout est en rouge.
-On n'a pas intérêt à y aller, quoi.
-Exactement.
C'est vrai que l'opération,
maintenant, il y a
une sorte de consensus,
en disant que d'intervenir
avec l'opération Serval,
ça avait peut-être un sens,
mais il aurait tout de suite,
une fois les villes du nord
libérées,
qu'il y ait pas
d'opération Barkhane,
qui était une opération
extérieure à l'ancienne.
Et en fait, c'est vrai que, un peu,
ça sert, cette opération Barkhane,
cette présence de l'armée française
un peu à l'ancienne
servait déjà
de cache-misère
à une présence française
globalement en déshérence
sur l'ensemble du continent.
Il y avait de moins en moins
de Français dans les capitales.
On était plus dans la période
postcoloniale où la France avait
une rente politique avec des chefs
d'Etat amis qui avaient été
dans tout le dispositif
de la France en Afrique.
Je passe du coq à l'âne,
mais quand vous allez
au Museum de Bruxelles,
de Tervuren,
quand vous entrez,
il y a écrit en gros,
c'est un sociologue belge,
il y a écrit :
le passé,
tout passe sauf le passé.
C'est le passé qui passe pas.
Et la France n'a pas tiré
les leçons
de ce passé
qui ne passait pas.
-Beaucoup disent, mais en fait, pour
que la France garde une bonne image,
pour qu'elle soit acceptée
là où elle est rejetée aujourd'hui,
dans certains pays d'Afrique,
il faut démilitariser
et puis il faut revenir
à une espèce de partenariat
ou de coopération
qui soit justement dénuée
de tout aspect militaire.
Est-ce que c'est
effectivement une solution ?
-Ce qui est évident, c'est vrai que
le fait que cette présence militaire
à ce niveau-là,
ça a servi un peu de cache-misère
à une présence française
globalement en déshérence,
c'est vrai que la France
doit faire profil bas.
On entend le président Macron dire,
on doit être
en 2e rideau, etc. Mais
très franchement, pour l'instant,
ce qui était proposé,
ça veut dire avoir un peu
des sortes
d'académies militaires,
sur les anciennes
bases françaises,
avoir à côté des académies,
on voit pas trop
ce partenariat.
On comprend simplement qu'il faut
vraiment faire profil bas.
C'est une période historique
qui s'est terminée.
La France n'a pas vu
l'Afrique se mondialiser.
Elle a pas vu, pas simplement
les Chinois, les Russes ou autres,
mais ses propres
partenaires européens,
elle n'a plus son pré carré,
il faut passer à autre chose.
Et la meilleure façon,
c'est de faire profil bas
pendant plusieurs années.
-Justement,
vous avez écrit un livre
avec Pascal Airault,
qui est un journaliste français,
qui écrit dans L'Opinion,
qui s'appelle
"Le piège africain de Macron"
chez Fayard.
Et dans ce livre,
vous recensez, vous présentez
et vous décryptez la politique
africaine de Macron. Alors, Macron,
comme beaucoup de présidents
qui l'ont précédé,
il voulait tourner une page,
est-ce qu'il l'a vraiment
tournée cette page
de la politique française
en Afrique ?
-C'est-à-dire, Emmanuel Macron,
il est arrivé, il a été voir
les jeunes au Burkina Faso.
-Le fameux discours de Ouagadougou.
-Où franchement il a voulu tirer
l'ardoise magique,
en disant,
je suis jeune comme vous,
on va pas s'occuper du passé,
on replie les rétroviseurs,
on regarde devant, etc.
Sauf que le passé ne passe pas.
Encore une fois. A ce moment, il y a
le retour de l'inconscient,
le retour du ressentiment, le retour
d'une période historique.
A un moment donné,
Emmanuel Macron a compris
qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose.
Il y a eu les rapports
mémoriels sur le Rwanda.
Il y a eu le rapport
sur l'Algérie,
le rapport maintenant
sur le Cameroun.
Alors, il dit, je confie
le passé aux historiens,
mais simplement, ça fonctionne pas
comme ça.
La politique est
toujours au coeur
de cette présence française
en Afrique.
Et les jeunes, ils ont envie
de parler de cette période.
Ils ont envie de parler,
pas forcément de la période
de la colonisation, mais
de cette période postcoloniale,
quand un certain nombre de chefs
d'Etat qui sont encore au pouvoir
et qui ont été installés
souvent par la France
depuis ces années justement
de cette Françafrique,
depuis 30, 40 ans, etc.
-Et les fils de aussi.
-Exactement, les dynasties.
Donc, à partir de ce moment-là,
ils ont envie de parler
de cette période.
Les présidents qui sont là
sont les fils des gens
que vous aviez installés
il y a 30 ans,
parlons-en. Pourquoi ils sont encore
là ? Les soutenez-vous encore ?
Quelle est votre attitude
à leur égard ?
Et on peut pas dire,
on va s'occuper que de digital,
on va s'occuper que de com',
de culture, etc.
Ils ont envie
de parler politique.
Les relations... Sauf que
l'Afrique est totalement
mondialisée et du coup,
la position de la France,
qui fait plus
que 4 % de parts de marché
par rapport à la Chine qui fait 18 %
et les propres partenaires
maintenant,
on parle peu de la Turquie, mais qui
est extrêmement active et présente,
à partir de ce moment-là,
même Emmanuel Macron,
on l'a bien vu, il est allé,
quand il fait ses voyages,
il va à Canosa maintenant
quand il va au Cameroun.
Tous les pays d'Afrique centrale
qu'il avait boudés
au cours de son 1er mandat,
maintenant il y va,
mais à Canosa voir Paul Biya,
Denis Sassou au Congo,
Ali Bongo au Gabon.
Il avait boudé ces pays,
en disant,
sortons de la Françafrique,
on va aller que dans les pays
anglophones et lusophones,
sauf que ça fonctionne pas,
ils nous attendent pas.
-Justement,
il est allé et ça,
c'est pas une première,
mais il a beaucoup souligné ça,
il est allé au Nigéria,
il est allé au Kenya,
comme s'il se tournait
d'ailleurs
vers les pays qui économiquement
en Afrique sont forts.
En se disant, la relation
que la France doit entretenir
avec l'Afrique, elle doit passer
par le commerce, par l'économie,
parce que, sur le reste,
ben, on est un peu marginalisés.
Est-ce que ça marche, ça ?
-Non, parce que...
Les fameuses phrases sur la proie
et l'ombre et autres.
On voit bien que c'est vrai
qu'Emmanuel Macron, il a dit,
pour sortir du pré carré,
on va entraîner
les entreprises françaises,
tout le business français,
vers les pays anglophones
et lusophones.
Sauf que...
-C'est donc Mozambique
et Angola. Et Guinée aussi.
-Anciennes colonies
portugaises,
mais c'est vrai que, quand vous avez
vécu dans une rente politique,
même pour le business français,
vous étiez chez vous en Afrique
pendant des années,
les entreprises, très souvent,
les contrats, ça se faisait
en téléphonant
au président et autres,
vous passez pas comme ça
d'un business français
qui a ses problèmes aussi
de responsabilité, RES ou autres,
au niveau responsabilité
sociale et autres,
c'est vrai
que les jeunes cadres,
quand il faut vous affronter
des pays comme la Chine,
la Turquie ou autres,
pas trop regardants
sur la corruption dans les pays,
c'est vrai que maintenant,
le business français en Afrique
est pas forcément adapté
aux nouvelles situations
pour se battre.
-Antoine Glaser,
c'est quoi le modèle chinois
par exemple en Afrique ?
Comment ils s'y prennent ?
-Les modèles chinois,
c'est très simple.
J'ai vu ça à un moment donné
à une construction
au Gabon, ils disent d'abord, oui,
on va prendre des employés gabonais,
et puis, un ministre gabonais qui
me dit off, vous savez, on a essayé
de mettre un certain nombre
d'employés gabonais le matin,
mais ils ont pas fait
la journée.
Ils font tout de A à Z et en plus,
ils le financent.
-Les Chinois font tout de A à Z.
Ils font venir la main-d'oeuvre ?
-Ils font venir
la main-d'oeuvre aussi
et ils disent
aux dirigeants africains,
si vous avez pas l'argent,
vous inquiétez pas, on s'arrangera.
Et ils se paient
en matières premières
ou ils se paient différemment.
Mais en fait,
ils endettent les pays.
Il y a un endettement de l'Afrique
vis-à-vis de la Chine exorbitant.
Et comme les Chinois se sont fait
titiller sur cette affaire-là,
ils ont commencé à annuler une
partie des dettes, mais globalement,
ils sont maintenant hyper puissants
dans énormément de pays.
-Est-ce qu'ils ont
une bonne image ?
Les populations locales
les acceptent-ils ?
Ou est-ce que
ça commence à tourner ?
Est-ce qu'ils s'exposent
à des critiques
en raison de ces pratiques ?
-Ils s'exposent à des critiques,
mais honnêtement,
il faut surtout pas que des Français
le disent aux Africains.
Mes copains africains
disent toujours,
c'est pas à vous, les Français,
de nous faire la leçon,
attention aux Chinois,
aux Russes, etc.
On s'en débrouillera.
Il faut arrêter.
On est mal placés pour ça.
Bien évidemment, les Chinois,
ils vous mettent des routes
comme ci, des routes comme ça,
ils disent non, c'est pas à vous.
Il faut arrêter l'infantilisation
de l'Afrique. Ils se démerdent.
C'est dur à dire,
mais c'est démerdez-vous.
Ils se débrouilleront,
c'est leur problème.
C'est leur problème, pas le problème
de la France. Il faut arrêter.
-Elles sont où,
les forces de l'Afrique ?
Sa démographie, par exemple ?
-C'est la démographie.
Il y a une énergie,
moi qui suis en plus ancien,
les Africains sont sympas,
ils disent pas les vieux,
mais moi qui suis un ancien,
vous rentrez ici,
quand vous rentrez en France,
on sent le manque d'énergie.
Sur le grand marché d'Adjamé,
où j'ai failli mourir étouffé
tellement il y a une pression,
il y a 1 million d'habitants
dans un quartier d'Abidjan,
c'est presque autant que l'ensemble
du Gabon, mais vous avez
une pression évidemment
démographique importante,
mais c'est leur problème,
ils se débrouillent.
Mais il y a
une énergie faramineuse.
-Et néanmoins, il y a
quand même un truc terrible
pour eux, c'est cet exil
et ces migrations, qui
ne touchent pas les plus pauvres,
mais les gens qui ont
les moyens de partir.
L'Afrique se vide de ses forces
vives d'une certaine façon.
-Oui, bien sûr, mais encore
une fois, on peut pas amalgamer.
Ce qui m'a toujours fait rire,
on dit toujours,
oui, on va faire
les leçons au Niger,
en disant, il y a
7 enfants par femme,
sauf qu'il y a pas
de Nigériens en France.
J'ai appelé un copain
à l'ambassade,
il y a pas plus de 14 000, 15 000
Nigériens, je parle pas du Nigéria,
Nigériens du Niger, de Niamey,
de la francophonie.
Il y en a pas.
Vous avez peut-être 300 000,
400 000 Maliens,
mais vous avez pas de Nigériens.
Il faut voir selon les pays.
Il faut pas tout amalgamer.
Ca n'a rien à voir. Beaucoup
de Nigériens, vous les retrouvez
en train de faire
un certain nombre de travaux
d'utilité publique
comme on dit dans des pays
comme le Gabon
ou du golfe de Guinée.
-Il y a une immigration interne
à l'Afrique.
-Bien évidemment. Les gens
n'imaginent pas que Lagos,
c'est 20 millions d'habitants.
Il y a des dynamismes et des trucs
qu'on ne maîtrise pas
et on fait toujours
des clichés à partir de Paris.
-Et il y a aussi la culture
africaine qui commence aujourd'hui
à avoir un rayonnement énorme
dans des domaines d'ailleurs
qui sont très divers,
parce que continent de l'oralité,
moralité,
il y a plein d'écrivains.
La mode aussi. La mode.
La cuisine. Enfin, ça infuse.
Je dirais que l'africanité
d'une certaine façon infuse
toute la culture internationale,
c'est la mondialisation, ça.
-C'est la mondialisation
et c'est apprendre de l'Afrique.
On voit bien comment, dans
tous les domaines de la culture,
il y a vraiment à apprendre
énormément de l'Afrique.
Vous allez avoir, même si c'est
aux Etats-Unis que ça s'est passé,
quand vous avez Basquiat avec Warhol
qui vont faire une expo à Paris.
Mais c'est l'Afrique et c'est là
où il faut apprendre de l'Afrique,
et cette culture-là est
extrêmement importante,
c'est ça qui peut aussi
revivifier
à travers un certain nombre
de diasporas ici
qui considèrent que dans les postes
de responsabilité en France,
dans les entreprises, il y a encore
un plafond de verre pour eux,
mais pour un certain nombre,
il y en a justement,
par contre, sur la culture,
sur la musique et autres,
mais il faut pas que ça soit
un prétexte pour cantonner l'Afrique
toujours au sport
et à la musique.
Il faut pas oublier
ce plafond de verre
pour un certain nombre de gens
qui sont français comme nous,
mais qui n'ont pas accès
à certains postes à responsabilité.
-Si vous reteniez
une figure qui symbolise,
qui incarne l'Afrique,
pour vous, ce serait laquelle ?
-Il y en a deux.
Pour les jeunes,
c'est Thomas Sankara.
-Qui était le président
du Burkina Faso.
Qui a requalifié
le Burkina Faso.
-Il est inévitable,
parce que c'était pas simplement
la révolution,
il y avait une volonté
de se réafricaniser,
que ce soit les vêtements,
la nourriture, etc.
-Pays des hommes intègres.
-Oui, mais surtout valoriser
absolument le continent africain.
Et il y a Houphouët-Boigny,
qui est pour moi
le vieux président africain.
Pourquoi ? Parce que,
contrairement à ce qu'on pense,
il gérait son Afrique de jour
avec un certain nombre
de gouverneurs, plutôt d'ailleurs
des Antillais. Il gérait
la modernité entre guillemets
avec la France, mais il mangeait
africain, il gérait la nuit.
Il avait son Afrique de jour
avec les Français,
il avait son Afrique de nuit
avec les Africains.
C'est une image très forte.
J'ai connu comme ça un
de ses conseillers qui m'avait dit,
il m'envoyait au Burkina Faso,
qui était l'ancienne Haute-Volta,
apporter de l'argent
au chef des Mossis du coin.
Et puis, je rentrais
avec des poulets,
avec lesquels ils faisaient
des sacrifices et tout.
C'est l'Afrique de jour,
l'Afrique de nuit.
-Merci, Antoine Glaser.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA
"Uncatchable",
Alexandr Zhelanov
...